good afternoon and welcome to today's
press conference conference depress
today we have with us Health Minister
Jeanie Duco Dr Ramona Nemer the chief
science advisor Dr Michael Strong
president of the Canadian Institutes of
Health research and Dr Teresa Tam Chief
Public Health officer for the public
health agency of Canada my name is Mia
Robson and I will be moderating the
press conference today if you are online
and have a question please use the raise
hand function we will be taking
questions in the room first and I'm told
we'll have about 30 minutes for
questions after the statements are are
made and we will start I believe with
the minister Duplo
across the country are facing major
challenges and emergency rooms are
overwhelmed health workers are
experiencing significant strain and are
running out of stream
Canadians are extremely concerned and so
am I Canadians patients caregivers and
health workers all want results and we
remain committed to working
collaboratively with all our partners to
do things differently
we will do so by focusing on the ends
rather than the means because as we can
see now the old way of doing things does
not work
I remain committed to working with my
provincial and territorial counterparts
to improve health services for everyone
and that is why at last month's health
ministries meeting I confirm that we are
ready to further increase health care
Investments through the Canada Health
transfer in addition we are ready to
invest more in funding through
tailor-made agreements with provinces
and territories that will allow us to
provide better care to Canadians
we owe it to Canadians to come together
and find immediate and longer term
solutions to address those challenges
this brings me to my first update
parents and caregivers have been
particularly concerned about their
difficulty to find children's analgesics
as of today over 2 million additional
bottles of these medicines have been
made available to parents and caregivers
through increased domestic Supply and
foreign importation
I can also I can also confirm that the
drug company Elon estimates that an
additional 800 000 bottles for this
month will be available at pharmacies
and retailers across Canada
the influx of new products should help
parents manage their kids symptoms at
home as we continue to experience a
surge of respiratory illnesses across
the country
with cold and flu season after an
earlier start than anticipated we need
to protect the overburdened health
workers by doing everything we can to
stay healthy especially as we enter the
holiday season
that includes staying up to date on our
vaccinations
there are safe and effective vaccines
available for both the flu and covid-19
and these are available to everyone in
Canada over the age of six months
and today is a great anniversary in that
regard
two years ago on that exact date the
largest vaccination campaign in the
history of Canada was launched 95
million doses of vaccines against
covid-19 have been administered since
then
the national advisory committee on
immunization has also recently
recommended that children six months of
age and older can safely receive a
covid-19 vaccine at the same time as
other recommended childhood vaccines
including the flu shot
this being said we're still learning
about covid-19 and there remains much to
learn about how it affects human health
over the long term
what we do know is that even a mild
covid-19 infection or reinfection can
cause real long-term consequences for
individuals communities in our health
care System
evidence show that almost 15 percent of
adults who were infected with covid-19
experience longer-term covid-19 symptoms
the nature and severity of these
long-term effects can vary from person
to person and these effects are
collectively known as postcode 19
condition also referred to as long covid
to support Canadians who are living with
the longer term effects of that virus
the government of Canada is working with
all experts to better understand this
condition
in July 2022 Dr Nemer Canada's Chief
science advisor established the task
force on post-cover 19 condition to
develop a scientific framework for
managing long covet
Pursuits conditions
translation
foreign
foreign
virus May develop long-term symptoms
suggesting that covid-19 can develop
into a chronic illness
these symptoms range from muscle pain
shortness of breath and extreme fatigue
to what's called brain fog
gastrointestinal issues and even heart
palpitations
collectively they've come to be known as
postcovid19 condition or PCC also known
as long covet
we don't fully understand what causes
certain individuals to develop PCC or
what leads to the different disease
manifestations
we don't know why women are twice as
likely as man to contract it
we don't know why it can accelerate the
onset of other chronic conditions like
diabetes and heart disease
but it is evident that PCC is a serious
condition that can have at times
irreversible Health consequences
in light of all this as the minister
said I brought together experts and
practitioners from across the country to
provide the government with advice on
ways to address PCC in Canada
in developing the recommendations which
we are releasing today we looked at
existing scientific evidence and heard
from Healthcare Providers and people
with lived experience
we spoke with many people who are
suffering life-altering physical
impairments
their stories were heartbreaking
one individual reported feeling trapped
in their own body and others said they
were treated with disbelief in the
workplace
still others recalled feeling abundant
by their community
and several reported difficulty
accessing health care and social support
most had lost their job
and this is my other point beyond the
health problems PCC also affects the
daily lives of people
from their ability to work to caring for
their families to interacting with their
communities
and this can have significant societal
impacts for example estimates from the
U.S suggest that 10 million people with
long covet could carry an economic cost
of 3.7 trillion dollars a year when you
take into account lost quality of life
lost earnings and higher spending on
medical care
with 1.4 million people in Canada
already reporting symptoms it's not
difficult to imagine the serious
ramifications for our own economy
clearly the risk of the disease is not
evenly distributed yet its impacts will
be universally felt
so what do we do
to start we need to acknowledge that PCC
is real that covid-19 manifests itself
as an acute but also as a chronic
illness
in addition to their well-known
protective effects against severe covet
19. it is now clear that vaccines also
contribute to reducing the risk of PCC
patient care what we learned from
addressing PCC will likely benefit a
broad range of Canadians including those
suffering from other infection
Associated chronic conditions such as
Lyme disease a condition that may become
more common due to climate change
V2 virus still spreading and the
Healthcare System already overburdened
it is vital that we act now to care for
affected individuals and protect many
more from serious post-infectious
complications thank you and now I'll
pass it on to Dr Strong
I'm pleased to be participating in
today's event alongside Minister duklo
Dr Tam and Dr Nemer at the Canadian
Institutes of Health research we've been
heavily engaged in Canada's research
response to covet 19. we work closely
with the public health agency of Canada
and our federal Partners to identify
research gaps and priorities
from the start of the pandemic the
government recognized the important role
of research in mounting a response to
this
that's why CHR received significant
dedicated funding for covid-19 research
beginning in 2020.
we have used this funding to rapidly
mobilize Canada's research communities
to generate evidence needed to
understand the virus and to make
decisions on how to best protect
Canadians
as the pandemic evolved over time so too
has our research response
the first projects funded in the spring
of 2020 a focused on containment
measures such as vaccines Diagnostics
and Therapeutics
I think I might mention at this point
Canada was one of the very first
countries in the world to mount a
unified research program after that we
LED in many areas
later research has focused on the
broader impact of covid-19 on the health
of all Canadians particularly vulnerable
groups such as children and seniors and
the impact of caring for coveted
patients on our hospitals
to keep one pace with the emergence of
new variants such as Omicron we funded
the coronavirus rapid variance rapid
response Network also known as kovarnet
in March of 2021.
this network is composed of researchers
from across the country who have
produced Vital Information on the
different virus variants to help guide
our Public Health response and to
prepare for future pandemics
as the minister and Dr Nemer have noted
post covid-19 condition is a serious
issue affecting many Canadians
this is a new condition for which we are
still defining its clinical features and
determining how best to treat it and
support the recovery of patients it is
critical that we focus our efforts on
understanding this potentially
devastating disease
as part of our ongoing research response
we have already funded some research on
PCC or post covid-19 that will
contribute to this understanding of the
condition
for example we are funding the Canadian
covid-19 prospective cohort study or can
Cove for short
this study involves more than 2 000
patients in Canada's four hardest hit
provinces Quebec Ontario Alberta and
British Columbia
the study will help us to better
understand both short and long-term
outcomes in patients and their
caregivers
today Minister duclow has announced an
important new step in the evolution of
our covid-19 response this is the
creation of a new national network
focused on post-covet condition as
clearly alluded to by Dr Nemer and her
task force as being a need
this network will be supported with 20
million dollars in new funding provided
to CHR in last year's budget
we designed the network to ensure
alignment with the goals and actions
outlined for research in Dr nemer's task
force report and as such the objectives
to the network are very focused
it will first and foremost provide a
platform to strengthen Canada's capacity
for research on post covid-19 condition
it will enable comprehensive And Timely
understanding of the biological clinical
mental health health systems and
population Health impacts of postnocovid
19 condition
it will engage relevant stakeholders at
the local National and international
level to support coordination of
research activities and lastly it will
swiftly mobilize research evidence to
support an equitable response to the
post-covet 19 condition
as cihr we launched a competitive
process to create the network in October
this process was led by the center for
research on pandemic preparedness and
health emergencies an initiative of the
government which is housed at cihr
the research center was set up to
continue to address covid-19 and to help
us ensure timely research and highly
trained experts are in place for future
emergencies
we will be ready to announce the
recipients of the funding of this
network early in the new year
the work of this network will make a
major contribution to achieving the
vision of the task force report in
supporting Canadians affected by post
covid-19 condition and reducing its
impact mercy and thank you very much
thank you very much
nationally Sasuke V2 influenza
respiratory sincitio virus or RSV and
other respiratory viruses continue to
cause significant levels of infection in
our population
very young and elderly people as well as
those were pre-existing medical
conditions continued to be at the
highest risk of serious illness
while increases in respiratory virus
related illnesses are expected at this
time of the year
co-circulation of these viruses is
causing significant strain on our health
care System
path to Canada the
secrecy respiratories
um
indicators including clinical and
Wastewater testing show that SARS curvy
2 is still circulating across the
country and while we are past the peak
of the last of the 19 Resurgence is too
soon to let our goddamn
in Canada variations in population level
of immunity and current Global Trends
suggests that an uptick in covid-19
could occur in the new year
in recent weeks genetic sequencing data
on SARS Kobe 2 viruses show continuing
increase in immune evasive variants
notably bq1 and BQ 1.1 while the
previously dominant ba5 lineage variants
are declining
with the increased prominence of these
variants in Canada at a minimum we could
see a slower Decline and a higher
plateau in the number of infections as
well as Hospital admissions in Canada as
these respiratory viruses and as this
respiratory virus season plays out
in terms of the other respiratory
viruses circulating RSV activity has
leveled off nationally and infections
are declining in some jurisdictions
this means activity levels are now
within the expected range for this time
of year
in contrast influenza is continuing to
Trend well above expected levels for
this time of the year but this varies
across the regions
most worrisome is the increase in
influenza-related hospitalizations
the impact Network which provides data
on pediatric hospitalizations due to
influenza has noticed sharp increases in
multiple sites across the country
these data also suggests a shift to a
higher proportion of hospitalized cases
occurring in the 10 to 16 year age group
compared to Seasons prior to the
pandemic
however the highest cumulative
hospitalization rates for influenza
continue to be among children under five
years of age
currently the weekly number of pediatric
hospitalizations being reported is above
levels typically seen at the peak of the
influenza season
tragically due to this High number of
pediatric cases you're also seeing
higher than usual number of ICU
Admissions and deaths due to influenza
in children
is
indicate that this year's influenza
vaccine is a good match to circulating
strains and therefore is likely to help
protect against serious influenza
disease influenza vaccine takes about
two weeks to provide optimal protection
so as we rapidly approach the holidays
now is the time to get vaccinated if you
have not already done so flu shots are
available across Canada and can be given
to adults teenagers and children as
young as six months of age the flu shot
can also be given at the same time as
the covid-19 vaccines there are now more
options for covid-19 booster doses for
children 5 to 11 years of age and the
recent approval of a bivalent vaccine
for this age group
it has been six months or more since
your last covid-19 vaccine dose on
covid-19 infection getting vaccinated
now will boost your level of protection
going into the holiday season
staying up to date with the recommended
vaccines provides an important
foundation of protection
the results are the first
population-based survey of adults across
Canada conducted between April and
August of this year show that close to
15 percent of those with the confirmed
or suspected covid-19 infection
experience longer-term symptoms or
post-covered condition with almost half
of these individuals experiencing
symptoms for a year or longer
while ongoing studies are needed there
is emerging evidence that the risk of
developing post covid-19 condition is
reduced if you have received two or more
doses of covid-19 vaccine prior to
infection
as we move indoors and gather to
celebrate the holiday season I encourage
you to build on the foundation that
vaccines provide by taking additional
personal protective measures together
these measures can provide very good
protection against covid-19 as well as
other respiratory infections
when planning a holiday gathering
consider the potential impact of
respiratory illnesses on your health and
social plans the health status and risk
factors are the people you're gathering
with and the Places You'll Be gathering
in
properly wearing a well-fitted
well-constructed face mask in indoor
public spaces or crowded settings and
taking steps to take the best
ventilation possible are layers of
protection that can reduce everyone's
risk
[Music]
our Health Care Systems continue to be
challenged by the additional burden of
all respiratory viruses this time of
year
the impact particularly on children's
hospitals has already been overwhelming
in many parts of the country this
holiday season let's do the best weekend
to make our wishes for health and
happiness Come True by taking actions to
protect ourselves and others from
respiratory viruses happy holidays
joyous fat thank you merci migrich
thank you we'll start with questions in
the room with one question and one
follow and our first question will go to
Laura Osmond from the Canadian press
foreign
hey there my first question is for the
minister
um I wanted to jump off of what you were
saying about the government's
willingness to increase the Canada
Health transfer and if I'm I'm hearing
you correctly also explore more tailored
bilateral agreements but the provinces
um I spoke to Adrian Dix last night who
said that he's still not clear exactly
what the government is looking for in
order to get those negotiations moving
forward so I'm hoping that you can kind
of pull the curtain back a little bit
explain to us exactly how these
negotiations work and what conditions
you've put to the province and and kind
of a timeline for getting those talks
moving
thank you and I will gladly do so at
taking the curtains back as you say and
that make that brings me back to uh the
last year during which we had uh 12
meetings at the health ministers level
obviously many more meetings between the
officials and and many others and during
those 12 meetings with the leadership of
Minister dicks in particular and the
leadership of other provincial Health
ministers we made very serious and good
progress on two big pieces uh the first
one was how to support healthcare
workers to retain them better to recruit
them to recognize their credentials uh
to uh to train them and then and then on
data and because data saves lives how we
can have in Canada a modern Health Data
System that provides data to to Health
Care Providers to nurses doctors
Specialists Physicians pharmacists so
that the data on People's Health are
available when these people end up in an
emergency department on the visit there
there their physician or they go to
visit a pharmacist so how do we make
sure that that data supports the their
health and in the work of workers
and we were going to the Vancouver
conference with great hopes that not
only would we finally agree on all of
that great work that Minister dicks and
others had done but also we would share
that that work publicly unfortunately
just a few days earlier my health
ministers received in order by their
premiers not to speak about those
results publicly and that's what that's
the unfortunate uh that's an unfortunate
thing because before we come to the
means that we need to achieve some ends
we need to agree on the end and to speak
publicly about them and the results that
that come from you know investing in
workers and supporting patients so where
we are now is we're continuing our
conversation I've met all my health
ministers have been speaking to them
almost weekly in various ways and we
know we'll get to a an agreement on
outcomes at some point
but we need more work and we need and we
need premiers to let us do that work
based on my conversation with Minister
Dix he was under the impression that he
doesn't know what the federal government
wants and they might be willing to give
it if they knew what the federal
government was looking for is is the
ball in their Court to come to you or is
it up to you to tell them exactly what
criteria you're looking for
the ball is in the premier's court
at the half Ministry level we all agree
we've got a greater great relationship
we agree on the diagnostic we agree on
the problems and the solutions to those
problems we were in total agreement in
Vancouver in private the problem is that
the premiers don't want us to speak
about those outcomes and those results
they want to maintain a futile file to
fight on dollars and that's refutile
fight because they ask for 35 percent if
you do the calculations correctly we're
already at 35 if you do what dreamers
ask us to do if you add the whole
package know that the cash transfers and
the the the the transfer that come with
the the tax points we are 35 roughly
speaking we're a bit above 35 during
Colby in 19 which we're roughly at 35
now and we've been at 35 for the last uh
50 years almost now in addition to the
to CHD the tax points as we all know we
have been investing and we keep
investing uh in the fight against
covid-19 72 billion dollars in total
plus all of the additional transfers for
Home Care Mental Health Care and
long-term care not even mentioning the
two billion dollars additional that we
sent from a few weeks ago to reduce
backlogs and surgeries
and and Diagnostics so on the dollars
it's not a useful fight no it's if if we
were to only focus on 35 we wouldn't we
wouldn't do anything more but the Prime
Minister did commit that we would be
investing even more on in terms of
resources but we need to agree publicly
and speak publicly on the results based
on the hard work that Minister addicts
and many others did in the last year
next question will be Valerie bean from
Radio Canada
um
my answer is that if we're talking about
Financial Resources the Canadian
government is already doing a lot and
even much more than what the provinces
are asking for this is 35 that the
premiers are talking about we're already
there if you do the calculations
correctly if you do the sum of uh
transfers of cash transfers there's a
Canada Health Care transfer and
transfers
a little bit over 35 years
billion dollars that continues to help
provinces and territories fight against
covet 19. bilateral agreements and
investments in home care long-term care
and mental health if you uh
to try to reduce the surgery backlog
there are huge sums of money and much
more
of what engineering
federal government generally sends to
the provinces and territories in March
the Canada Health transfer will go up
another ten percent
the right discussion is what what are
the results that we want to reach
together the good news is that all the
Ministers of Health including myself
agree in private we agree on what needs
to be done in order and even transform
our health
better access to family doctors
and to train more health care workers
the skills of foreign
right now
all Ministers of Health agree on what
needs to be done but in public we don't
yet have the authorization of the
premiers to speak about it and to focus
on results
Kevin Gallagher CTV News
so if it's in the premier's court
and the Premiership saying the Prime
Minister will meet with them
and the Health Care Systems in a crisis
and as you acknowledge the hospitals are
in a crisis
what's the short-term solution to give
any of these hospitals that are turning
away patients or you know transferring
patients elsewhere some relief can the
federal government do anything right now
in the short term
[Music]
well the federal government as I said a
moment ago now has been sending is
sending and will be sending very
significant additional resources to
support the difficult work of my
colleagues Health ministers their job is
not easy with the viral situation of
which Dr Tom spoke a moment ago it's
very difficult in in hospitals and in
healthcare contacts across Canada so my
job is to be an ally of Health ministers
to make sure that that significant and
additional funding that our government
has been has been committing to
is being received by by Health ministers
and that's the case with a two billion
dollar just recent investment in in
supporting Health our our Health Care
system and more particularly hospitals
in the context of backlogs of surgeries
and treatments the
equally important work that we need to
do together is to look at the longer
term our Health Care system is
has been under severe demographic
pressure over the last few years and
over the next few years it will be under
increasingly heavy demographic pressures
and to do that to to address that
pressure we need to have a more Modern
Health Care System a healthcare system
that invests for instance in sufficient
access to family health teams a lot of
our patients now end up in a hospital
because you don't have a family health
Team to go to or they end up in a
hospital because not having had an
access to a family health team they end
up with more severe health conditions
and then it becomes a lot more complex
and a lot more difficult and more costly
and unfortunately a lot less good in
terms of health
care and health conditions to end up in
the emergency department as opposal
having been able to visit a family
health provider prior to this in
addition to that as I said a moment ago
it's about data and modernizing our
health care System making sure that safe
and appropriate information on patients
is accessible by Health Care Providers
and investing in home care and mental
health care and long-term care as we
have promised to do and as we're doing
now see but you're saying the health
ministers that you meet with agree with
those
reforms and changes that need to happen
to the system however hearing from the
provinces that they're they want to meet
with the prime minister they want to
move forward on getting the healthcare
transcripts increased so what's holding
this process up you're you're blaming
the premiers
the premiers are blaming the Prime
Minister where's the truth
well premiers do I have important
responsibility Health ministers have an
equally important responsibility and we
need to be given the room
to to take on that responsibility we
were able to do that
we're prepared to do that and we were
hoping to do that in Vancouver just a
few weeks ago unfortunately the premiers
asked us not to uh not to do that work
what sir what can't you share them
confused what is it that you can't share
the pre the premiers aren't allowing you
to share I just I want to make sure I'm
hearing you correctly the premiers are
forbidding the health ministers that you
spoke with that have an agreement of
some type to move forward with not to
share am I overstepping that or my
misunderstanding something yeah as you
said and as you heard uh earlier there
were two key plans one on supporting
health workers and one on modernizing
our our health system including however
having a modern Health Data System in
Canada we were prepared
to approve those plans and to meet them
public but we were asked by premiers not
to do so
Emily
um
foreign
um
foreign
[Music]
of provinces and territories with
regards to managing Healthcare
Healthcare Services
the government of Canada will not uh
say that they are better place to manage
Health Care in the provinces and this is
important and it is also my first
responsibility is uh to work in respect
of the different jurisdictions and this
is a very a difficult jurisdiction to
have Mr Trudeau will probably also say
that we have a shared responsibility our
roles are different but shared because
we are serving the same citizens with
the same funding coming from the same
pockets and also Canada in Canada
the Canada Healthcare act that requires
of the federal government to assume a
share of responsibility then we have the
focus on results we know that this is
the National Post
ah yeah this question might be better
directed to the doctors so the minister
can take a time out
um the report here the executive summary
identifies that 1.4 million people have
long covet that you don't know what
causes long covet in terms of the you
know the medical interaction there
um and really don't have any idea how to
treat it
I'm wondering in that context where does
the research begin to try to solve those
problems and is the money that the
government has allocated so far anywhere
near uh sufficient
maybe I'll I'll start and then perhaps
my my colleague Dr Strong will will want
to add
um we know that uh the post covet
syndrome is due to infection by uh by
sarsko V2 is due to the acute phase of
the Kobe so this this thing we know what
we don't know is what causes
um heart problems for example or
cognitive problems to persist or to
reappear uh weeks and months after the
acute phase has resolved okay
so in terms of treatment
again you know we mentioned that it's a
it's a complex disease so you can think
of the treatment in a way in in three
different buckets one is treating
symptoms
um that we know something about for
example heart palpitation for example
hypertension for example you know if if
there is a diabetes onset the second one
is treating
um mental health
you know issues
we have at least treatments for that the
third one which is the most vexing is
how do you treat
ill-defined symptoms so brain fog for
example or chronic fatigue or you you
get you know exhausted just from going
to your medical appointment and this is
where we need a lot of research to
understand what's going on and we also
need perhaps to try and see if any of
the existing treatments for other
diseases can be repurposed and this is
in the context of you know clinical
studies so Mike
so again thank you very much for the uh
the question I may tackle it in three
different components there for you so
your first one was with regards to how
do we treat it what was your second one
but I'll come at it first uh for that
like the very first thing that one needs
to really be looking at in this is that
the best treatment for this is the
prevention of getting it and that is
Crystal Clear we are starting to see
very nicely from international data and
as Dr Tam alluded to getting the vaccine
and having at least two uh two doses of
the vaccine actually does reduce the
risk of going on to get the disease in
the longer term so the very first thing
is that be vaccinated we have highly
efficacious vaccines they do work the
second is is that with regards to the
actual causes behind it we are beginning
to understand this an awful lot more but
it is the first time that we've seen
this this illness this is an incredibly
unique scenario for us to have had an
acute illness as Dr was referring to
that then becomes chronic consequences
so there are at least three reasons why
we see the the illness going into the
post-covered condition first one is is
that there is undoubtedly damage that is
done at the time of the viral infection
itself so whether it be the heart
whether it be the lungs whether it be
the peripheral nervous system it doesn't
matter and that damage is lifelong in
many scenarios particularly for the
lungs right so that's a concern for us
there is an immune response that is
immediately mounted by this this virus
Works to try and suppress the ability of
the body to mount the immune response
that would be required to kill it and in
doing so it sets off an immune response
that is not only immediate but long term
add that to the damage that's already in
place you have ongoing the third piece
of this is that the virus itself appears
to be able to have longer-term
consequences particularly in some of the
degenerative disorders the neurological
disorders with that so if you take all
three of those I Circle back to my first
comment
we have never been in a scenario where
we've been able to look and see the
coming of a disease such as this and
know that the way to prevent it is to be
vaccinated
and so even if a vaccine
primarily helps to reduce the load on
the healthcare system which is critical
for it
our argument and the thing that I would
urge and I urge my colleagues to do is
get vaccinated not just because of that
but because it reduces the risk of these
long terms so we know a fair bit there
and we're beginning to understand the
research a very final comment on that is
we are as Canadian researchers we have
been incredibly fortunate in that the
funding that we've received to to look
at this has been over and above all the
other research that we do around health
issues and allows us to work extremely
closely with International groups that
are doing exactly the same type thing so
there's not redundancy we're trying to
understand this in real time so it's a
long answer but it's a terrific question
so I hope I gave you what you're looking
for
and Mr on Healthcare and on these
meetings with uh premiers and health
ministers you know everyone in this room
I think is having trouble understanding
what happens next because we have health
institutions that are calling in the Red
Cross to help out a children's hospital
in one of the richest countries in the
world and we seem to have no movement
from either side I understand your
desire for more long-term fixes to the
Health Care System but in the short term
the hospitals are overwhelmed so what
are you telling Canadians is going to
happen you're just going to wait until
someone blinks
about on dollars or or there no we as I
said the CHT increased by five percent
last March we added another two billion
dollar just a few weeks ago it will
increase Again by 10 in this March we've
we're sending uh other dollars for other
things too and it's never been as never
been as extensive in terms of financial
support and if it were only dollars
provinces and territories could also use
their their dollars on average they have
a surplus now in Canada so it's it's not
about dollars the dollars are there
either from the federal government or
within the coffers of provinces and
territories but even if that's not the
case the Prime Minister said that there
will be even more dollars in in the
future and possibly in quite in the
short term but for adjusting our system
transforming our system making it more
adapt to to the reality of 2022 and
Beyond when Canadians can't have access
to a family health team that leads that
brings Canadians to emergency
departments when healthcare workers are
tired exhausted they leave and then
and once they leave the patients cannot
be cared for appropriately when patients
and providers can't share data Health
Data then it leads to issues of safety
and adequacy of of Health Care
David Thornton CBC News
hi good afternoon everyone
my questions from Minnesota
um Canada will receive another shipment
of pax livid in the coming days
but based on the data that we've been
looking at the treatment has not been
widely used so what will your government
do to boost the uptake and the use of
paxilvid
well that's a great question and there
are two angles to that the the second
angle I'll turn to Dr Tam to uh to
answer it because there has been a
recent
I understand recent evidence biomedical
evidence or the effectiveness of of
paxlovid which you might be interested
to uh to know more about but on the
first part which is the accessibility do
we have indeed sent
hundreds of thousands of paxilvid
units over the last month it started
early in the winter and then we'll be
there to uh to share whatever provinces
and territories required to to care for
for patients as you might hear from Dr
Tamina moment it has an impact not only
of reducing the severity of of acute
covid-19 but you can also have other
benefits without introductor time for
that for that part
thank you for that question I think
there's a number of things that we can
do to increase tax level use it's
correct that the federal government has
sent I believe at least 700 000 those is
to the province and territories
so I've been disconnected from our
colleagues and also the clinical care uh
professional groups
as to why and how you know why practical
over it isn't being mobilized as as much
as we think it could be utilized
there's there's several different
factors I believe one is
um awareness for patients that this is
an option so I think we can collectively
do more in that area particularly those
with high-risk conditions or seniors
increasing their knowledge of how to
access Pax lovid in their local area but
also the benefit of pax lovid which has
been demonstrated not only in the
clinical trials but in real life now
that they can significantly reduce
hospitalizations and deaths in high-risk
groups particularly in seniors that
group should talk to the Physicians
ahead of time get prepared because if
you get diagnosed with covid it may be a
bit late to try and figure out where you
can get Pax loaded
and you need to take it within a short
number of days so know how to get your
rapid tests and know ahead of time where
you can get your packs loaded is
important Healthcare Providers I think
have been a bit concerned about using
Pax lovid because of the drug drug
interactions we know that that can occur
but collectively people can figure out
which patients can still use paxilovid
and
um and I think increase awareness and
education amongst health professionals
is something that we can assist with
um and then there is access
because you have to access a test and
then the drug really fast
and you've seen in Ontario just recently
that they've announced pharmacists can
now prescribe Pax lovid after someone's
got a positive rapid test
at the beginning we had a we didn't have
a lot of Supply so people insist that
you have to have a you know positive
covert test
and then in certain groups and they've
widened the eligibility in provinces now
so that more people can get it and get
it faster I don't think that's the same
method everywhere but I think Sharon
Burke's practices on how we mobilize it
more I think will be very helpful
particularly in seniors
just to follow up
we budgeted some 2 billion for Kobe
treatments including paxilvid Minister
are you concerned that there will be
waste
Dr Tom do we um
do we know do we have evidence that
there is has been wastage in the use of
packs of it now I don't have specific
numbers all I can say is we have to
follow the science on the evolution of
the variants as well
some of the most recent variants uh BQ
1.1 Etc are immune evasive those
monoclonals don't work
so that will be regular need to not use
them because that would not be helpful
to patients so I think that's totally
understood
so we now have antiviral agents like
pacslovid and also ramdasovir that has
to be given not by orally so it's much
more difficult to give potentially but
there are these options where the
viruses have not eluded uh the drug
Effectiveness and these can continue to
be used but we have to monitor
susceptibility of the virus to these
medications
and I do think that we mustn't let our
scientific
knowledge and biomanufacturing of these
drugs go to waste because we need to now
adapt them to future use as well but uh
I while I don't have the numbers I think
there's necessarily A need to park those
drugs for now if they don't work
I just want to add that this is a
perfect example why data sharing is
extremely important the reason that
pharmacists and the physicians may be
reluctant to prescribe
paxlovid which for Now is really the
best game in town in terms of you know
an antiviral other than of course the
best which is prevention is because they
they don't have perhaps the full file of
the of the individual they don't know
um you know what what other diseases
they they may have had in the past what
other interventions they may have had
what drugs they're taking and as Dr Tam
said there are you know known drug drug
interactions so you don't want to you
know be providing something to to an
individual that may harm their health so
I thought that perhaps it's like a a
good example of why you know this the
the the the the the
sharing and the availability of uh
Health Data is is absolutely important
for caring for for individuals thank you
do you have another question David
Rafael Pirro from qmi
um
playing with the numbers
well uh
and so foreign
accessible to the healthcare providers
[Music]
we'll have time for one or maybe two
questions from zoom and we'll start with
Mike Crawley from CBC
thanks for taking my question
um my questions for Minister du Khloe
um you mentioned data saves lives and
one of the biggest concerns in the flu
season as Dr Tim mentioned is the impact
from children and there's a piece of
data that we've been wanting to find out
which is the the deaths of children from
flu British Columbia was transparent
about this they announced when there
were flu related deaths from children
but other provinces are not giving out
information about uh children's deaths
from the flu so Minister duclow what do
you believe should be the policy here
should there be transparency or is it
right to keep this information Secret
well let me first say that these deaths
are tragic deaths no this these These
are numbers but more importantly and
much more importantly these are real
children families
grandparents and parents who who are
grieving the loss of those uh of those
children
having said that
yes data saves lives no obviously we
don't know whether it would have been
possible or possible to save those
children's lives with better access to
data but as Dr Nemer said a moment ago
and as Dr Strong knows really well and
has Dr Tam knows really well with her
work with other public health offices
across Canada data does lead to better
treatments overall but also better
treatments adapted to the conditions of
the patients that workers are there to
uh to look after and in Canada
unfortunately we don't have a a
world-class Health Data System we have a
mediocre class data system and we need
and we can do a lot better the great
news is that all Health ministers agree
uh that we should and must do better and
the equally great news is that we will
be there as the Prime Minister said to
support those efforts through increased
uh supports to uh to provinces and
territories
well my follow-up is for Dr Tam
um from the perspective of Public Health
uh is it best to publicize uh statistics
around deaths from something like the
flu and children
for the purposes of as British Columbia
did uh in encouraging parents to to get
their their children vaccinated
uh information is uh extremely important
for informing
um the population about measures it take
to protect themselves so that that is a
fundamental uh aspect of public health I
think
one thing is clear that of course
something like influenza we know happens
every year doesn't get as much attention
or hasn't been paying as much attention
as covid has
we've gained some
um capacity
from the covet experience to show that
we are capable of monitoring
specific health information in real time
in the time of a urgent situation so I
think we can build on that experience
one thing that I do have to clarify is
that
children do get serious outcomes from
influenza although majority of them if
they rest up properly can recover at
home
but particularly the youngest kids and
we are also in a special situation that
we're just coming
into increasing contact POS three years
of reduction in contact during the
pandemic
I think because the numbers are small
which we're grateful for the numbers are
deaths
Hospital provinces are often very
careful about privacy
so even British Columbia until you get
above the number five it's
it's difficult we don't we don't get
that level of reporting nationally too
for the fear that individuals can get
and identify very easily
that is something that we have to work
through because
um that that is important to individuals
but instead of data custodians we need
to be Davis Stewarts and manage
appropriate data but also informing the
public so that they have the information
that they need
just while I have the mic and I did
finally packs a little bit numbers so we
did allocate over 700 000 treatment
courses of pax lovid two Province and
territories
while we've procured 1.5 million courses
we have a lot of Rapid tests that have
been sent out so together in combination
uh these two measures can help reduce
the impact of covid-19 particularly in
the high-risk groups
okay and we'll take one final question
on Zoom Alice Gerard wase from LA Press
how many deaths in Canada can be
attributed to PCC
I think the simple answer is we don't
know yet uh and um you know that's
another area where data is unfortunately
um missing from across the country it's
very difficult really to even the the
CDC in in the U.S said that they believe
this may be underestimates because there
is no clear definition uh and and
medical sort of description
um but here in in Canada I think that
we're we're still figuring this out
[Music]
[Music]
it is important
do you have something to add
really I would simply Echo what Dr
Neymar has been saying as well too but
you know for those individuals who you
know have symptoms that are persistent
for that period of time and they're you
know one of the one of the issues behind
all of this is that many of those
symptoms can in fact look like other you
can be misdiagnosed in the sense of they
are fairly subtle or their cumulative
look so one of the first things that we
recommend right off the top is ensuring
that you are seen by a multidisciplinary
team or by specialists in the area to
make sure that this is not just simply
ascribed to being PCC so number one on
that is kind of get it right and make
sure that you're being looked after
there the second is that we don't have
specific therapies that will bring a
full stop to this right now but there's
a lot of symptomatic therapies that can
be done and and Dr Nemer started to
allude to those the final piece is that
like everything that you know we've
we've looked at and had to face over the
course of the last several decades of
new diseases coming it takes time and it
takes research to get those answers but
we're this is the right direction this
is what needs to be done so I'm
encouraged that we're moving and the
report to Dr Nemer is helping to guide
us on that
thank you so much this will conclude
today's press conference